At
Ucla on telling you a story
because it's pretty damn easy.
So there's this neurological condition
virtually comprehensible.
What happens if you have any,
you,
you have a stroke in the right.
Uh,
the right priority area of
your right hemisphere has,
it doesn't happen.
What happens if you have that stroke is
you lose the lending side and the loss
is extremely interesting.
Firstly,
it gives you lose motor
control so you can't move.
But that's really the beginning of it.
You lose your ability to conceptualize
the fact that you had a left side of your
body and more.
You lose the ability to conceive
and we don't know how this happens.
I think it must be something like if I
stand here and look out at all of me,
I can see that people right
in front of me quite clearly.
And then the people to
my right and left tomes,
I keep my eyes big savings
right in front of me.
They're quite blurry.
I can't see their faces on the way,
no other people.
And then by this are out at the
periphery of my visual system.
I don't even have color vision anymore.
Even white tape it for the test
showed that and then past that,
which is behind me.
There's nothing,
it's not black.
It's not an amputee,
it's just not there.
It's not even,
it's not even not fair.
It just doesn't exist.
And what seems to happen with people
who have neglect that moves around the
three corners of
everything instead of half.
Now that's a gap because
we really don't know.
But if you get people
who like to draw a claw,
they'll put all the numbers in one half
and if can give you a plate full of
food,
they'll only eat the food on
the right side of the plate.
And then if you turn the brake bill,
he half of what's left and
then even more strangely now,
and then they notice that they have a
left heart and it really upsets them.
So the,
and they noticed they have a
left arm and they'll try to,
they'll be horrified by it.
They'll think in someone else's.
They'll think extremely someone
that they know or that we did.
The nurses left the body and sometimes
they'll even try to throw it out of bed
and so and so they don't seem to buy.
And here's the other thing,
strange strangers,
they're not upset about the fact
that they're half paralyzed.
It's because they actually don't know
that they're half parallax and the reason
for that specific part of the brain
that would alert them to the fact that
they're half paralyzed as
being destroyed by the stroke.
So it's,
it's they're not have sex at all white.
The apartment would make
them upset because you should
be upset if you lose half
your body.
It's like that's very upsetting.
And the fact that you get upset is your
emergency to the importance of the loss.
And so imagine you can
carry me a little bit.
Well then would you
notice and answer as well?
We not.
And so what grandma Sean was
experimented with the balance,
literally the balance of
people who have neglected.
He did this weird little experiment
that you do to test people's vestibular
system,
which enables them to
stay on felons consultant.
If you pour cold water in someone's ear,
then it upstairs have sense of their
balance because your ears are intensely
involved in your balance and your
eyes are moving back and forth and it
destabilizes the seas.
And so around the Shaundra was testing
his neglect patients for their,
for their,
uh,
their particular function
using cold water.
A number of them woke up and
realized that they were paralyzed.
And his idea was
essentially that the shock,
eventually the shock of the
cold water was enough to,
to increase,
say,
emotional functioning enough to
reactivate the damage efforts in the right
hemisphere to wake them up enough
to notice that half you're going,
he was missing.
Thank you.
Produce a catastrophic people show
response when people realize what had
happened.
Um,
so if you call the attention
of someone with neglect,
the left him say you have
a left hand there and say,
can you move it?
And he'll say,
well,
never mind.
I don't feel like it hurt my
arthritis is for you this morning.
It hurts me to come up with
some rationalization for
why they can't move it,
but they're upset.
So Robuchon none with irrigating for years
and then they wake up and they have a
catastrophic emotional response to the
loss of the live side of your body.
But then 20 minutes later they snap out
of it and then they forget they lost the
left side.
They go right back to
their old way of thinking.
And what's so interesting about this
and how it's related to whatever he told
you is that sees their left hemisphere
had already built a board with their body
and you know you haven't
more than with your boy.
It's really BPL walk when you,
you can tell that magic
if you break a tooth,
what happens if you break your tooth?
It's your tongue goes absolutely insane,
right?
Your next three months,
all your tongue is poke round in there.
Figure out exactly the contours of your
problem and maybe it takes you three
months to update that too.
You don't feel like your
bones is a stranger.
And the reason for that is,
well you should let him know which in
your outright like clearing your mom just
unbelievably wide are not insensitive.
And so because why?
You put things in there and you have to
eat and so you have the intelligence of
what's you and what isn't for you.
Choose your town like,
I mean it's very important to
have that map that you see.
You see with your experience
with having a damage tooth,
you see just how much work it takes to
even do a little tiny bit of remapping,
right?
It's like three months of of Tom,
the effort to update your
will over your mouth.
Imagine how much effort it would be
lucky we'll take to update your model of
your body if you've lost half of it.
Right?
So that's it.
So your left hemisphere count do that
keeps on process in your body with the old
model and since the right
hemispheres damaged,
there isn't any emotions
associated with the loss.
And so the left hemisphere just keeps
on grinding away on its own logo on.
And that happens to us and
walk like that's sort of
how we think is that we have
these partial models of reality more or
less work and were really stubborn about
and we don't want them to disappear
because they take a bloody modern work to
formulate.
And if we're forced to lose the
mega trends to be catastrophic.
And so an example of that might be,
you know,
let's say you put a whole bunch
of effort into up monogamous,
you know,
monogamous relationship.
And so actually it's lasted 10 years.
What's the African?
Okay,
well the first PBS,
you've gone a lot of places with this
person and that model claims with them.
You have a story and the story's based
on your understanding of that person and
the implication of that understanding
for your understanding of you.
So you know,
you might be,
well I took my,
my wife or husband to Hawaii
and we had a nice time at God.
You have that whole memory and you
have hundreds of memories like that.
All secrets to national story about who
you are and where you are in the past.
And then you have a story like that about
the present who you are now and then
give a story like that about your future.
And then you find out that your partner's
been having sequential affairs for the
last 15 years and it's like,
well what happens all your
models now in development?
And then you think,
well what does that mean exactly?
Well,
it doesn't just mean that you
don't know who your partner is,
although we greeted means that it also
means everything you thought about your
past isn't wrong.
All those memories of,
of everything that happened,
those aren't accurate.
And so when something like
that happens in DC trail,
this is why Dante betrayers
in the lowest level of hell,
by the way,
besides safety itself and chase Deniece,
this is the betrayers because it blows
out your model up in the past and the
presence of the future.
You told me about where your are,
we don't know where you were and
you don't know where you're going.
And it's worse than that because you also
don't know who you are anymore because
you are obviously someone who just wasn't
that awake and you were with Justin
wasn't who you thought they work.
And so it's no wonder you'd be
resistant to information like that.
You know what I mean?
It's like who think out.
Once they have a global theory of
that magnitude disprove that globe,
it just leaves you wide open
and exposed to the world.
So we heard your tech,
your,
your theory is as much
as you possibly can,
and I'm going to overthrow them because
of some housing will disapprove pretty
to,
you know,
psychologists talk about
that as confirmation bias.
Like Sam,
think about it as a cognitive
that they no be moaning.
The fact that people are very stubborn
about giving up their presuppositions,
but it's so bloody one little,
you know,
it's,
you put a lot of effort into
that formulation of the world.
It's not just a representation,
right?
It's the way you live in the world.
And so when you give that up and then
what the hell are you supposed to do?
Right?
You're supposed to be enraged.
He supposed to have a 50
supposed to become herbivorous.
Are you supposed to
collapse into depression?
It's supposed to be
like infinitely cynical.
Are you supposed to never have
a relationship in your life?
Are you supposed to have complete contempt
for yourself for being seen nine even
blind,
or you're supposed to hate you mad at
him because it contains the capacity for
that kind of betrayal.
It's like you don't know.
All of those things are true
all at one civil paisley,
and that's the little
space that you occupy,
right?
That's the mythical
underworld essentially.
That's a place you go when
your dreams and hopes die.
Everyone goes there from time to time.
Lots of people go there
and never come out.